qu'est ce qu'il vous faut quand on parle
d'un nouveau smartphone de chez lui eh
bien il vous faut un crayon et il nous
faut une feuille
surtout quand on lui a parlé de la gamme
renminbis qui est tellement grande que
c'est compliqué de s'y retrouver
aujourd'hui on va parler de ce
smartphone là on va parler du renmin 10
5 g de chair au mit parce que oui chez
oh oui il ya plusieurs renminbi à leur
ennemi 9 bis le renminbi prolos rémy le
10 5 g leurs ennemis notre 10s chier au
bout de toute façon ils sont là pour un
petit peu complexifier l'histoire et que
les espèces de nébuleuses ont du mal à
comprendre ce qui se passe mais là on
comprend et on comprend très bien que
dans cette gamme rémy 9 10
eh bien on un smartphone 5 g qui est
fait pour utiliser de la salle j'ai
kiffé pour se connecter en 5 j alors ce
qu'on va faire je vais vous aider parce
que je sais que c'est compliqué même moi
des fois j'ai du mal à m'y retrouver
on va regarder à quoi sert ce raid mine
de 10 5 g en quoi il est différent du
renminbi 4g evo 4g et 5g on aura compris
comment s'oriente ses différents modèles
dans cette petite gamme renminbis est ce
qu'il est intéressant est ce qu'il faut
l'acheter à quel prix comment tout ça
alors on va dégrossir sont faits simples
et on y va maintenant
[Musique]
c'est toujours très compliqué c'est
chiant mais très très compliqué à
regarder on va regarder ça réd me not
not avec eux disent ça c'est la gamme
rémy notice vous avez le modèle qu'on va
appeler le modèle normal le modèle
normal c'est celui là
et ce modèle normal il a une déclinaison
qu'on va appeler le modèle professionnel
je vous ai déjà fait une vidéo sur ces
deux modèles je vous invite à aller la
voir elle est intéressante parce qu'elle
nous permet de comprendre déjà qu est-ce
qui va départager ces deux modèles à le
modèle normal vous en douterez et bien
il est un poil plus standard a
fonctionné avec une caméra de 48
mégapixels ok ça va très très bien sûr
leproux on va aller beaucoup plus loin
au niveau de la photo ap avoir un quart
temps avoir un sens 8 mégapixels ça
c'est vachement bien aux abords un
processeur un peu plus boosté la
batterie il va être sensiblement la même
chose donc ça c'est dans cette vidéo que
je vous ai déjà fait que je vous invite
à venir voir et là vous êtes sur des
smartphones qui sont 4g et xiaomi a pris
le pas le pli a voulu en tout cas les
sur autre chose avec une version 5 g on
reste toujours sur renminbis mais par
contre pour avoir de la 5g si on a dû
changer le processeur on n'est plus ici
sur un processeur qualcomm on est plus
serein stade ragone on est chez mediatek
on est sur un divan city 700 et se
démène city 700 il est super intéressant
pour un point vraiment c'est qu'il vous
permet d'avoir une double carnage hocine
5 g ce qui fait qu ici vous avez deux
cartes sim si vous souhaitez 5 g + 5 g
pour avoir la 5g +5 gilou faut des
abonnements qui supporte de la double 5g
il vous faut un abonnement singer plus à
notre abonnement 5 g on peut imaginer
une carte perso une carte pro les 2,5 g
on peut imaginer pour les frontaliers si
vous êtes ensuite pourquoi pas une carte
sim française 5 j'ai une carte sim
suisse 5 g ça fonctionne très bien donc
ça on peut la voir et ça c'est grâce aux
dîmes entity 700 donc ça c'est cool
exposition médiatique qu'il est
intéressant il est extrêmement bien
placé en tarifs dans cette gamme de prix
vous avez une version 4 + 64 qui coûte
229 euros et vous avez le 4 +128 qui lui
coûte 269 euros ce qui vous en fait l'un
des smartphones les mieux positionnés du
marché mais pour arriver à vous proposer
un smartphone 5 g avec double 5g et à ce
tarif là on va se dire à 229 euros bien
il a fallu faire des choix
et oui forcément la singette ça coûte
cher ça coûte plus cher donc il a fallu
faire quelques petits compromis alors
les compromis tout est fait ici c'est du
compromis quand effet au niveau de la
photo sur votre renminbis vous avez
quatre capteurs photo un grand angle de
48 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 1.79 vous
avez un ultra grand angle de 8
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.2 ok vous
avez de la macro de 2 mégapixels qui
ouvre à f 2.4
je suis pas très fan de ça mais bon là
et vous avez un capteur de profondeur de
2 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.4 de la
même manière donc comme il a fallu
gagner sur les coûts café shiomi
et bien que vous à supprimer un élément
10 ans et d'écouté on vend d'enlever un
petit peu il faut on rajoute de la 5g
d'un côté il faut on enlevait un petit
peu ils ont supprimé l'ultra grand angle
ce qui veut donc dire qu'avec votre
smartphone 5g en fait vous avez ça vous
avez ça vous avez ça mais vous avez pas
ultra gandon ça veut donc dire que si
vous voulez un smartphone qui sera un
peu plus polyvalent photo avec cet ultra
grand-angle bien vous allez sur le
renminbi 4g si vous voulez ce qui se
fait mieux en photo dans cette gamme
raid minutes 10 vous allez sur le
renminbi pro mais si par contre vous
voulez de la dette tout en gardant ce
capteur de 40 eu mégapixels qui permet
de venir faire au moins une fois de
bonne qualité et bien vous allez sur les
raids minent 10 5 g on va garder ici par
contre la même chose au niveau de la
batterie ça c'est plutôt intéressant et
c'est normal dans cette gamme de prix
c'est à dire une batterie de 5000
milliampères heures donc ça c'est un
très grand standard une petite
différence ici là vous avez un chargeur
33 watts hockey ici par contre vous êtes
sûre du 18 watts
bon on pourrait dire que c'est un point
de détail a rien de bien grave ici les
techno drame sont exactement les mêmes
c'est la lp dédia 4x d'un côté comme de
l'autre donc ça ça ira bien
vous avez du stockage en fs 2.2 d'un
côté comme de l'autre ça marche bien
autre différence que vous avez entre la
version normale la version 5 g c'est
qu'ici vous avez un écran amoled l'aï si
vous n'avez pas d'écran amoled par
contre est ce qui est intéressant c'est
que vous avez quand même un grand écran
c'est un 6,5 pouces full hd plus et
surtout ici vous avez un taux de
rafraîchissement de 90 ans
que vous n'avez pas sur le modèle normal
alors si vous êtes sur le modèle pro
coûtera plus cher c'est du propre là
vous êtes carrément sur du 120 hertz up
la 120ème avec un taux d'échantillonnage
tactile de 240 air donc pour le game et
une plus plus plus elle promet si vous
n'avez pas de 5 g donc si vous voulez de
la 5g avec un taux de rafraîchissement
qui marche bien mais vous allez sur leur
ennemi note 10,5 j'ai donc pour le
gaming le rémi notre distingué il ira
bien pour plein de petits jeux on va pas
prendre les jeux les plus gourmands
ici on se parle bien d'un médiathèque
dit man city 700 donc si on récapitule
prochain avoir une vision un peu global
si vous voulez ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui dans cette gamme renminbis
c'est le pro si vous voulez un bon
compromis entre la photo la performance
le renminbi 4g et si vous voulez de la
5g avec une double nano 5g
en tout cas qu'ils supportent double
d'anonymes 5g et bien vous avez le
renmin 10 5 g en photo il ya un
compromis qui a été fait au niveau de
l'ultra grand temps que par contre vous
gagner en fluidité grâce à ce taux de
rafraîchissement 90 hier c'est pour moi
une propos qui est super honnête et
surtout un tarif qui est extrêmement
bien placé et c'est vraiment tout
l'intérêt de ce produit là c'est de vous
proposer la 5g un tarif hyper sexy 4,64
229 et 428 à 269
dans tous les cas quel que soit le
smartphone que vous allez choisir vous
tournez sur me wade 12 basé sur un
android
11 l'expérience est très bonne et je
vous en ai déjà parlé dans une
précédente vidéo
le design est bien c'est quasiment la
même chose un franchement y'a pas de
grande révolution bien retrouver un peu
cette idée qu'on retrouve cette année
chez ont mis au niveau de ce module
photo qui est très sympa vous avez un
capteur d'empreintes digitales sur la
tranche vous posez vos doigts ça des
verrous très rapidement ça marche bien
c'est sensiblement la même chose
là-dessus franchement il n'y a pas grand
chose à raconter
vous bénéficiez également d'une prise
jack ça fonctionne bien vous avez de
l'infrarouge droit une fois de plus chez
chuo miss un très grand classique dans
cette gamme de prix là le smartphone en
lui même est très standard par rapport à
ce qu'on retrouve chez chuo mis dans
cette gamme de prix s'inscrit dans cette
gamme rennes minaude 10 alors soyez
tranquilles et soyez rassurés si vous
voulez acheter un smartphone de schumi
si vous vous dites je n'y comprends plus
rien avec toutes ces références et c'est
normal du côté des millions du goût des
drm min 10 il y en a tellement qu'on s'y
perd donc là ça permet d'y voir un peu
plus clair de comprendre quelle est la
différence entre leurs ennemis notre
disque est jérémy no 10 5 g le rémi no
10 prouillac ans rémy indice est on n'a
pas parlé
bon apparemment un poil plus tard et je
vais vous faire une vie
au global extrêmement rapidement pour
vous permettre de savoir qu'est ce qui
se passe chez xiaomi parce que wish i
know me vous avez la gamme me vous avez
cette gamme ray demi il y en a de tous
les côtés il ya la gamme i mx même si
des choses qu'on verra pas tout ce que
le minix folle enfin tout ça on en
reparle très bientôt vous invite donc à
venir vous abonner pour tout savoir sur
ce qui se passe c'est shiomi une fois de
plus le petit bouton rouge est juste là
si les rouges c'est que vous n'êtes pas
abonné bien évidemment si vous avez des
questions sur ses smartphones de shiomi
on en reparlera plus tard j invite donc
à venir laisser toutes vos questions ou
interrogations suggestions en bas en
commentaire ici je vous montre de la
faute aux juments pas de la vidéo parce
que c'est pas un smartphone qui fait
pour aller faire de la vidéo clermont
donc on va se regarder de la photo est
assez rapidement parce que c'est des
capteurs qu'on a déjà vu sur le renminbi
4g il ya luttera grand-angle en moins
mais sinon c'est la même chose on voit
que sur le capteur principal ça
fonctionne pas trop mal c'est pas la
voir des photos les plus contrastées on
le voit notamment ici là ne serait-ce
que de ce côté là au niveau de la
cheminée néant monde à bien les détails
derrière au niveau du ciel on voit bien
aussi les feuilles devant c'est pas très
saturé 1 c'est un peu le le petit défaut
de ses smartphones mais on n'est pas non
plus sur la gamme photophone ici chez
xiaomi on peut venir se rapprocher en x
2 si on souhaite que ça commençait à
venir un petit peu lissé x 2 ça
fonctionnera sur 40 une méga pixels mais
on va pas aller au delà
parce que si vous allez au delà jusqu'à
1 x 10 et bien oui tout de suite ça lit
c'est pas beau et c'est normal on peut
faire des photos et de la macro la macro
je suis pas il prahic rafale il faut
trouver la bonne position si on veut on
peut
la caméra de cellfish fonctionnent
globalement pas trop trop mal la phrase
tu as alliali c'est un peu mais une fois
de plus rien d'anormal ici et voilà on a
fait le tour on a fait tour alors j'ai
pas besoin d sur des photos nues ici si
vous voulez aller voir mon test rémy
note 10 4 jérémy nos dix pros tout en
une seule et même vidéo vous verrez on
va beaucoup plus loin au niveau de la
partie photo mais ici clairement c'est
ce qu'on retrouve ces histoires de se
remettre un petit peu de temps et de
voir ce qu'il en est capteur principal
ça ira le reste c'est un peu en dessous
voilà pour ce tour un but rapide de ce
smartphone parce qu on a déjà parlé
on connaît cette gamme chez xiaomi on
connaît ce smartphone c'est une sorte de
faire un petit refresh pour be
positionné dans la gamme dites moi vous
ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire avec un trio se retrouve
très vite pour continuer bien évidemment
à parler je suis en vie parce qu'a
toujours plein de choses à raconter sur
la marque et même quand on a vu arriver
le dernier smartphone et bien il est
toujours poussé par un autre smartphone
c'est une histoire sans fin
on en reparle bien évidemment sur ce
premier soin nous les gros bisous
l'amour est un très vite très vite
ciao